madame la Première ministre les maires
sont inquiets inquiets devant une
situation économique aussi inattendu que
brutale l'inflation
osdrastique du coup des énergies
os des produits alimentaires qui pèsent
sur le budget de nos cantines scolaires
ou encore la hausse du point d'indice
devant cette situation la réponse du
gouvernement et trop timide voire peu
opérante trop timide comme la hausse en
2022 de la DGF qui ne masquera pas une
baisse tendance ni même ne permettra de
juguler l'inflation peu opérante c'est
le cas du filet de sécurité on a vu que
les ambitions étaient fortes et qu'à
l'arrivée peu de communes pourront
bénéficier en 2022 de ce filet de
sécurité le Sénat dans le cadre de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
jouera son rôle pour essayer d'ouvrir le
champ des communes éligibles au filet de
sécurité mais notre inquiétude ne
s'arrête pas la même la première
ministre notre inquiétude c'est aussi
vos propos lorsque vous appelez
finalement
à privilégier le lien entre les
présidents d'intercommunalité et les
préfets où sont les maires dans tout ça
notre inquiétude c'est aussi l'absence
ou la faible réaction du gouvernement au
préconisations de la Cour des comptes
qui invitent à ce que la DGF soit versée
aux intercommunalités alors ma question
madame la Première ministre elle est
très claire croyez-vous encore en la
France communale et si tel est le cas
nous attendons comme les mères des
preuves d'amour